SWAPNEEL KSHETRAMADE:
Hey, everybody.
My name is Neel and I'm
a program manager over
at the Google+ team.
I'm also an author of
this publication on Medium
called "Storytelling in VR."
I hope you'll check it out after
you hear what I have to say.
So after the headset
explosion in 2014-- well,
the headset announcement
explosion, really,
in 2014-- people
started discovering
a lot of applications for VR.
I mean, gaming, education,
sports, communication.
And they're all good
ones, but the one
I want to talk about
today is movies, narrative
entertainment.
[ONE PERSON CLAPPING]
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
One person, thank you.
But you all should
be interested,
because movies are big business.
2015 projected revenues
for filmed entertainment
about $90 billion US dollars.
And these are projections.
Digi-Captial-- take it
with a grain of salt.
But virtual reality
revenue is projected
to be around $30
billion by 2020.
Movies are going to be
a big chunk of that.
A lot of that is gaming,
sure, and headsets,
but movies are going to
be a big chunk of that.
So a lot of people have
been trying to figure out
how to make movies on VR.
It's not the
easiest thing to do,
but there's a bunch of
studios that have come up.
There's Oculus Story
Studio, there's
Felix & Paul in New York-- oh,
sorry, they're in Montreal.
Chris Milk is in
New York, and we've
got our very own
sort of ATAP Studio.
If you guys haven't seen
"Help," you have to.
It's incredible.
But there's a lot of
problems sort of identified
with making movies in VR.
People are trying to apply
the rules of movie-making,
and they don't really work well.
I mean, in movies, story
is told through a frame.
So if you have sort of two
guys having a conversation,
there's a framing shot.
And then throughout
the conversation,
there's cuts to one
person, then the next.
And there's reaction
shots and all that.
And suppose an explosion
goes off in the background.
They pan out and show
you the explosion,
and then zoom in debris,
the aftermath, reactions,
all that good stuff.
It's all in the frame.
The director tells you what to
see and points the frame at it,
and that's all you get to see.
In VR, the viewer is
in your environment.
There is no frame.
They're immersed in it.
They don't know where to look.
You don't know how to
tell them where to look.
Without cuts, how are they
going to pay attention?
If they miss a crucial bit
of the action, what happens?
I mean, what happens
if there's an explosion
and they're looking
the other way?
So let me tell you a story.
100 years ago, the Lumiere
brothers invented the camera,
and for the first few
years, they didn't really
know what to do with it.
I mean, there were little
films like a train pulling
into a station, which was
literally just a train
pulling into a station.
Or there were market scenes,
scenes of everyday life,
some slapstick comedy.
And in 1903, this guy
called Edwin Porter,
he worked with Edison, he made
a movie called "The Great Train
Robbery."
It's a 12-minute movie
about these four bandits
who hold up a train, and
they're killed in the shootout
afterwards.
It was remarkable
for two reasons.
One, it was the first
complete story told on film.
I mean, Edwin Porter invented
a new sort of visual language
for how to tell stories.
He had cuts, he had cross-cuts
between different locations,
he had camera angles, and
movements, and close-ups.
And towards the end,
there was a shot
where the lead bandit
essentially just fires
a gun at the audience.
And for somebody used
to watching live plays,
I mean, that's huge.
I mean, somebody is firing
a gun straight at you,
but it was a movie.
It was incredible.
And the second reason
the movie is remarkable
is because it kick-started the
global movie industry we know
today, with the
Hollywood, the Bollywood,
and all the other
woods around the world.
So indirectly, Edwin Porter is
responsible for "Star Wars,"
"Game of Thrones,"
and "Breaking Bad."
So you've got him to thank.
Let me-- oh, there we go.
So the VR movie really needs
its train robbery moment.
We need to figure out
how to make this happen.
Let me skip ahead a little bit.
So what are the key
elements of a VR experience?
I'd say there are two of them.
One is that it's immersive.
You have a headset covering
your eyes, your ears.
Down the line, you
could have body suits
that let you feel
what's happening
inside the environment.
People are coming up with
treadmills and spheres
and stuff like that.
All these are accessories, and
I know that a lot of consumers
don't have them.
But this is a vision
talk, so I don't
have to talk about
practical concentrations.
Point is, let content
drive adoption.
Make good movies and then
people will buy stuff just
to watch the movie.
And the second one
is interactivity.
So it's great to be
immersed in a scene,
but it's not engaging
unless you can interact
with it in a meaningful way.
And there's a lot of ways that
we can sort of get signals
from viewers-- track their eye
movements, track their hands.
If they say something, sort
of see what they're saying.
Maybe down the line,
you have sensors
that can track temperature,
blood pressure, even heart
rate, brain activity,
I don't know.
All of that could go
into sort of customizing
the experience just a
little bit for every viewer.
Now, I don't mean to say
that it should be a game
or a choose-your-own-adventure
kind of situation.
That's not it.
You're telling a story.
There has to be an overall arc.
There has to be conflict, drama,
characters you can relate to,
an inciting incident,
escalating, tension,
resolution, and all
that good stuff.
But you can have
interactivity in small ways.
For instance, that conversation
we were talking about,
two people at a table.
Now, what if one of
them or both of them
occasionally glance across
at this third person,
the viewer, who is sitting
at the table with them?
Or somebody cracks a joke
and nudges the third person,
and that person feels it
through their haptic body suit
or something like that.
It's the little things that
go towards increasing presence
and making the viewer
feel like they're
a part of the experience.
Another way we could
do that, for instance,
is let viewers be a
character in the story.
I just want to play this
little clip for you.
This is from a cut scene
from the "Arkham Knight."
Watch this cop.
He's our character.
And as he walks
towards the diner,
the camera sort of swoops in
and essentially becomes him.
From that point on,
you're seeing everything
through his eyes.
He's a character in the scene.
The viewer is now a
character in the scene.
Other characters come
up and talk to him
and stuff like that.
This is just different ways
of presenting the story.
It's ideas, but I hope you
guys will sort of altogether
come up with this
new visual language
that we need to make virtual
reality movies really
compelling.
Hang on.
Let me get out of this.
This is stuck.
Ah, there we go.
There we don't go.
Hm.
Anyway.
Point is, the thing
with movies and movies
today is that it's the same
experience for everybody.
It's filmed once and everybody
sees the exact same movie
for as long as it's there.
There's nothing customized
to the individual.
A virtual reality
viewer has a headset on.
It's a viewership of one.
We should be able to
take this opportunity
to sort of make it a unique
experience for that viewer,
have them come back and
have different experiences
every time they come back.
So good luck and--
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]